ora quando mi è stato chiesto di salire
su questo palco mi sono posta il
problema di non riuscire a mantenere la
vostra attenzione
così di parlarvi di sistemi complessi
sicura di concedervi quella decina di
minuti di sonno necessari prima del
prossimo intervento ma perché scegliere
di rompersi la testa proprio sulla
complessità già la parola spaventa mette
paura
quindi poiché il mio problema è di
natura semplice ho pensato che il modo
meno traumatico per iniziare a parlare
di complessità fosse ricorrendo a
qualcosa di familiare
questo è un sistema complesso sono
insiemi di numerosissime parti
interconnesse dipendenti le une dalle
altre
dalle quali emergono proprietà e
conseguenze molto diverse rispetto alle
singole parti per esempio un branco di
cani a delle dei comportamenti che sono
diversi rispetto a quelli del singolo
pack del singolo cane infatti isolando
un cane non riusciremo mai a dedurre
quali sono le proprietà di branco a
prescindere dai nostri strumenti
questa è quella che definiamo una
proprietà emergente la complessità e
ovunque in natura nella società
impossibile non vederla qui per esempio
stiamo sempre vedendo una serie di
sistemi complessi concatenati spa di
loro
via via più piccoli perché più un
sistema è complesso più e diversificato
e più si evolverà auto organizzandosi ed
adattarsi diventando sempre più
difficile da controllare
in questo caso le immagini ci risultano
relativamente meno familiari rispetto a
prima
eppure stiamo a vedere
sempre più o meno la stessa cosa ovvero
una parte del sistema di prima
questo è un cane o meglio questo è
quello che succede all'interno di un
cane dai tessuti dalle dalle cellule le
strutture cellulari fino ad arrivare
alle molecole quando ci troviamo ad
affrontare un problema tipicamente
ricorriamo a ciò che ci è familiare agli
schemi ai linguaggi che ci risultano
relazionabili questo è quello che viene
definito un approccio semplice ma gran
parte dei problemi che affrontiamo oggi
sono di natura complessa e non possiamo
affrontarli con la stessa semplicità
altrimenti rischiamo di non vedere ciò
che realmente abbiamo di fronte
quindi questo questo vuol dire che
problemi complessi richiedono approcci
complessi ma complesso significa
complicato infatti complicato complesso
vuol dire intrecciato composto da più
parti quindi una rete complicato invece
vuol dire piegato avvolto su se stesso
un labirinto sciogliere una
complicazione può essere faticoso per
via delle sue articolazioni che a volte
possono essere anche numerose però
semplificare un sistema complicato è
possibile perché deterministico che vuol
dire vuol dire che è prevedibile non è
incerto invece con un sistema complesso
non è la stessa cosa un esempio
uno strumento scientifico infatti qui
abbiamo una serie di parti di variabili
connesse tra di loro però possono essere
anche connesse in una maniera complicata
per l'appunto però sappiamo esattamente
cosa fa ogni parte cioè non c'è
un'incertezza come in un sistema
complesso ma la complicazione è qualcosa
che creiamo noi perché come dire è una
conseguenza dei nostri tentativi di
ricondurre la complessità a dei sistemi
lineari di pausa effetto perché perché
vogliamo controllarli vogliamo
prevederne le dinamiche
questo approccio diciamo che funziona se
in teoria riuscissimo a prendere un
pezzo di realtà
isoliamo e poi su questo pezzo di rasta
applichiamo la logica matematica il
pensiero scientifico fino ad ottenere
dei modelli perfettamente funzionanti
siamo tutti contenti
dov'è che succedono le rogne quando
questi modelli e dobbiamo andare
comunque a reinserire da quel contesto
di relazioni da cui l'abbiamo estratti
e nel momento in cui quel frammento lo
andiamo a riposizionare nel sistema
succedono problemi perché non è detto
che funzioni
quindi a questo punto dovremmo inserire
altre complicazioni per sostenere questi
modelli ancora per un po
ed è così che nascono i nostri mal di
testa ma è anche il modo in cui la
scienza e i sistemi di pensiero si sono
evoluti nel tempo una doppia sfida
diciamo per certi versi cioè se
prendiamo se prendiamo per esempio un
attimo in prestito
cioè cercando di analizzare il complesso
in realtà suddividiamo la realtà in
strati di astrazione che vuol dire è
come se volessimo descrivere un
bicchiere di vino basandosi
esclusivamente sulle molecole contenute
nel liquido oppure su come la luce
attraverso il bicchiere non staremmo
descrivendo il bicchiere di vino
quindi solo perché i nostri strumenti
funzionano in certi ambiti non è detto
che funzionino anche nei nastri quindi
ci sono dei limiti
allora come affrontiamo questa maledetta
complessità
se prendiamo un attimo in prestito le 5
fasi di elaborazione di un lutto della
più blair ros
vedremo che ha in questo momento diciamo
della del mio spiccio e stiamo nella
fase depressiva perché non sappiamo che
fare
la vita l'andamento dei mercati la
società più i sistemi sono complessi
meno li si possono controllare quindi
questo non ci deve però paralizzare
dall'affrontare non è che ce ne stiamo
fermi quindi la complessità va prima di
tutto accettata dobbiamo imparare a
gestirla senza complicarla ed è per
questo che dicevo prima una doppia sfida
quindi da un lato esplorare l'essenza
profonda della complessità cercando di
farne emergere gli aspetti più
approcciabili e dall'altro lato dobbiamo
cercare di ridurre le complicazioni
superflue
un modo per combattere le complicazioni
e l'innovazione nuovi strumenti
cognitivi e non ci permetteranno
di concentrarci sulle esigenze e
collaborative di comprensione della
complessità e la collaborazione stessa è
un sistema complesso infatti più il
sistema sarà più saremo organizzati più
riusciremo a coordinarci bene tra di noi
meglio riusciremo ad intervenire nel
sistema no quindi proprio perché prima
abbiamo detto che sistemi complessi
richiedono approcci complessi
noi siamo un sistema complesso possiamo
intervenire un sistema complesso quindi
come dicevo l'innovazione è un modo per
intervenire ma l'innovazione in sé per
quanto fondamentale è fine a se stessa
se non appunto non rendiamo accessibile
non sono qui per distribuire soluzioni
rapide
non intendo ridurre la complessità anzil
affronta ogni giorno gli studi
scientifici che conduco s'incentrano
proprio sulle fondamenta chimico fisiche
della vita che sono appunto complesse ma
una cosa voglio farla se non posso
ridurre la complessità può ridurre le
complicazioni
questo sì nel mio caso le complicazioni
che sorgono dal limitato accesso alle
risorse fra i vari modi in cui investo
il mio tempo
costruisco strumenti da laboratorio a
basso costo innovativi e open source
mi limito a scomporsi nella loro essenza
e ad apportare qualche vantaggio in più
rispetto ai dispositivi già presenti sul
mercato perché un apparecchio non deve
necessariamente
complicato per indagare problemi
complessi infatti bastano una stampante
3d poche concorrenti elettroniche
opportunamente calibrate rispetto degli
standard scientifici sennò mi tagliano
la testa per ridurne i costi e per
consentire un uso più decentralizzato
accessibile e realmente inclusivo di
tali dispositivi
gli strumenti sono senz ombra di dubbio
importanti però sono solo oggetti
prendono vita nelle mani di chi da uno
scopo e sa usarli con ingegno
questo avviene solo attraverso la
promozione della curiosità e
dell'istruzione per imparare a gestire
la complessità vanno adottate strategie
pans disciplinari vuol dire che vadano
oltre la suddivisione delle discipline
servono più competenze più approcci più
persone che lavorano in parallelo ma
soprattutto anzi alla base di tutto
serve sviluppare un pensiero critico e
metterlo in pratica il mio contributo
per certi versi è minimo mi limito a
fornire strumenti e conoscenze ce ne
sono tantissimi in giro di strumenti e
di conoscenze anche online
il punto è che questi strumenti e queste
conoscenze non sono sempre accessibili e
necessariamente ideali oppure se lo sono
non è detto che si sappia come usarle o
cosa farne e quindi queste sono sono
altre complicazioni
necessitiamo in realtà di un cambiamento
educativo in quelli che sono i modelli e
gli obiettivi della comunità che vuol
dire donella meadows individuo 12 modi
diversi di intervenire in un sistema
dicendo però che gli ultimi tre punti
sono in realtà quelli che contano di più
e che generalmente vengono visti per
ultimi
ovvero quelli che sono gli obiettivi del
sistema la mentalità del sistema che è
determinata dagli obiettivi e poi
modelli che sono appunto determinati
dalla mentalità ora prenderò quindi in
prestito un esempio che è stato fatto da
gioito durante il global community baio
summit tenutosi a boston lo scorso mese
all'emmeti media lab è che un istituto
che lui stesso dirige tra l'altro il
gioco del monopoly e basato su del and
words game che è un gioco che è stato
inventato nel 1904 dalisi maggie è però
stato creato con lo scopo di insegnare
ai bambini di prestare attenzione alle
dinamiche del capitalismo mostrando come
mostrando come le proprietà e come le
proprietà e l'affitto conducano le
persone alla povertà
quando i partner brothers comprarono
questo gioco e lo resero poi il monopoly
che conosciamo tutti oggi non cambiarono
le regole del gioco cambiarono solo
l'obiettivo ovvero adesso il capitalista
sei tu e vinci se mandi i tuoi amici in
bancarotta non serviva a cambiare le
regole
serviva solo cambiare l'obiettivo e
cambiando l'obiettivo è cambiato
l'atteggiamento del sistema quindi noi
possiamo cambiare le regole e quanto
vogliamo ma se non ci focalizziamo sugli
obiettivi il sistema probabilmente
continuerà ad andare sulla rotta su cui
già si trova al massimo potremmo per
turbarlo un po e quindi sono i valori a
definire realmente gli obiettivi e
quindi pensare a quali sono i nostri
valori e importante se non più
importante dell'obiettivo
a tal proposito voglio portarvi
l'esempio di una delle comunità di cui
faccio parte
siamo appunto i partecipanti del blog
comune tibio summit tenutosi lo scorso
mese appunto boston
questa è una delle più belle comunità
con cui io abbia avuto il piacere e
l'onore di confrontarmi una comunità che
sento veramente di poter chiamare una
seconda famiglia e di cui sono
estremamente orgogliosa per il lavoro
che svolge il motivo per cui ve ne parlo
e il profondo bisogno che ha il mondo di
persone come loro di persone che siano
non solo istruite ma istruite alla
complessità di persone che non sentano
soltanto un senso di appartenenza quando
fanno parte di una comunità
invitano soltanto
negli strumenti e nella digitalizzazione
e la salvezza da ogni nostro problema
non ci salveranno
a meno che dietro non ci siano delle
persone che mettono al centro anche i
valori le pratiche e gli obiettivi
comuni definendoli in maniera chiara noi
nel nostro piccolo lo stiamo già facendo
e continueremo a farlo
un altro esempio di comunità eterogenea
che che mi sta molto a cuore che quindi
voglio menzionare vi è quella di hajjam
la international genetically engineered
machine è meglio conosciuta come gemma
una competizione internazionale di
biologia sintetica che a differenza di
quanto si potrebbe credere estremamente
eterogenea ci sono dei team molto
eclettici ed è aperto non soltanto a
studenti di tutte le età ma anche
imprenditori e laboratori indipendenti
ogni gruppo viene spedito un kit il
quale lavorare che lo stesso per tutti
contenenti migliaia di frammenti dna
creati da studenti e da partecipanti
comunque degli anni precedenti e con
questi con questi frammenti si si creano
dei progetti a propria scelta
ci si iscrive in primavera poi si lavora
nei mesi estivi localmente dove si
trovano i vari team e poi si va a boston
a presentare il proprio lavoro alla
gioia jamboree
nel corso degli anni tra l'altro sono
stati realizzati numerosi progetti di
rilievo e da jam alcuni esempi includono
dei biosensori diagnostici che sfruttano
batteri intestinali per cambiare il
colore delle feci in caso di malattia
oppure c'è anche il progetto di un
gruppo di liceali sottolineo liceali che
ha sviluppato due metodi per la cattura
di nano particelle inquinanti dai
sistemi di raquel reflue
oppure ci sono anche esempi di progetti
di bioarte è tra i più famosi c'è quello
di un team francese che ha praticamente
sintetizzato biologicamente l'odore di
una giornata piovosa e lo ha
imbottigliato quindi ogni anno si
iscrivono a questa questa competizione
dei team provenienti appunto da tutto il
mondo con idee uniche e innovative
tristemente nessun segnale ha
tristemente in italia ai gemme quasi
sconosciuta infatti hanno partecipato
soltanto 15 team nel corso degli anni e
questo è un dato molto basso rispetto
alla media europea e eppure il peggio e
meriterebbe molta più attenzione non
soltanto da parte delle scuole ma anche
da parte delle università
questi idilliaci ed apparentemente
utopici esempi possono essere sono delle
realtà concrete e lo diventano solo
attraverso l'educazione alla complessità
imparare a ragionare in maniera trans
disciplinare come dicevo prima può
richiedere molto tempo anche tutta la
vita prendete ora siamo tutti capaci di
farlo siamo tutti nati con la curiosità
di esplorare l'universo che ci circonda
e viviamo in un'era in cui è possibile
anche farlo non dimentichiamolo quando
non rispettiamo la complessità di un
problema minimizzano l'impatto che esso
può avere sul mondo e questo oltre ad
essere incosciente può essere pericoloso
necessitiamo di pensare meno alle
soluzioni a breve termine ed allenarci a
ragionare su quelli a lungo termine
non possiamo ignorare la complessità non
possiamo disinteressarsene perché ci
coinvolge tutti per ogni problema più
allarghiamo la visuale e accettiamo il
complesso maggiori sono le possibilità
di focalizzarci su ciò che è essenziale
per farlo serviranno delle ragionate
contaminazioni positive tema di questo
ted il contributo che ognuno di noi può
dare sembra minimo talmente tanto da
spesso farci destare dal prendere
l'iniziativa
eppure con qualche accortezza in più
potremmo davvero essere quelli
intricatissimo sistema in grado di
plasmare il futuro in modi che possiamo
solo iniziare ad immaginare
e questa è un'idea che vale la pena
diffondere grazie dell'attenzione
[Applauso]
cristina cipriano